so
every year like clockwork a new iphone
comes out that's a little better a
little faster a little stronger than the
last one and as we know apple is the
master of messaging so they give an
incredible on-stage presentation with
unreal video production they paint the
simplest prettiest picture of how this
is the greatest iphone they've ever made
the most powerful fastest iphone we've
ever made but they also do something
else very important standard practice
but they give the phone to reviewers
and they don't have to do this but they
do and everyone involved will have
essentially some date that they are
first allowed to talk about their
experience with this new phone now i've
been a reviewer for years we're
professionals our job is to take that
week and do all of our testing and take
all of our findings and find all the
things we like and all the things we
don't like and all the new features and
test all of the new claims and distill
them all down
into one piece
and that is a review and if you time it
all right you can publish that review
right when the contract we signed says
we're allowed to you might have heard of
this it's called an embargo so that's
what you're seeing when you see all this
first wave of reviews and impressions
videos about a product drop at the same
time the thing is every single one of
these reviews
is fundamentally
a balancing act because there's limited
time there is no possible way to
meaningfully test every single new thing
about every incredible new phone that
comes out and even if you do how much
time does that leave for writing down
all these tests and then analyzing the
results of these tests and that doesn't
even leave time for the production of
shooting the video of editing the video
the color correction the music all the
creative choices you want to make
there's just too much being a video
reviewer on youtube today
is like nine different jobs in one
so how do you decide what gets included
in that review
and how much has to hit the cutting room
floor so every review has its own style
some reviews you'll see are 5 minutes
long super dense some might be 10
minutes long even my own videos reviews
over the years have gotten somewhere in
the 15 to 20 minute range but that's in
an effort to give you as much
information as possible in as short as
time as possible i'm not trying to waste
anybody's time and don't forget on
youtube we also have audience metrics
and retention to think about it's a
balancing act so a review is basically
the art
of compressing and distilling as much
useful information as possible
into one piece
but because it's an art everyone's going
to cut different things from different
places and make different pieces
but not this video
in this video there is no time limit
this is everything you could possibly
want to know about my last five months
with the iphone 12 pro
and what i really think
[Music]
[Music]
all right so now that the limits are off
i'm definitely going to be getting into
the weeds a pretty good amount in
multiple pieces of this video you know
when it's happening but i still think
it'll be pretty fun when we do it now if
you're the madman or mad woman who's
just going to watch this whole video
straight through to the end
well you can see how long this video is
it's a good one buckle up grab a snack
but if your attention span isn't quite
that long well you can see there are
chapters below for all these different
topics so if you want to get into the
weeds on a certain topic you're curious
about you can do that too feel free to
click around also this video is mainly
based on the iphone 12 pro that i've
spent most of my last five months with
but anytime i reference other pieces of
the iphone lineup the 12 mini or the 12
or the 12 pro max i'll mention that too
let's get into it
[Music]
so the iphone 12 series has a refreshed
design this year which is always a big
deal in the phone world and the iphone
design just doesn't change as much as it
used to and i think that's pretty
important design is really what most
people look forward to and what seems to
identify the iphone forever i mean think
about it most of the time when you see
new iphone leaks or headlines or rumors
it's mostly design stuff right you're
looking at new case designs or new
dimensions or what is the camera bump on
the back of this year's rectangle going
to look like mostly because we already
know the next year's iphone is going to
be pretty similar to this year's iphone
but we just want to know what it's going
to look like the look and feel in the
hand is always the last most exciting
unknown i happen to love the new modern
super flat design of the iphone 12
series it's still a rectangle with
rounded corners in a few different
colors but the sides are flat straight
up 90 degrees stand up on the edges flat
so the flatness has become this
identifying characteristic of the phone
just like it was for the iphone 4 4s 5
and 5s but it's actually even flatter
than most other flat phones because
instead of 2.5 d glass that's flat for
most of the surface and then curves over
at the very edges this is just straight
flat glass on the front and the back and
the flat stainless steel band around the
edges so this has a couple of effects
first it gave apple slightly more
internal volume in the same shape
second it made the edges a bit sharper
so i happen to like the flatter edges
just because i feel like it gives me
something to hold when i'm picking up
the phone gripping it some people though
dislike it for the same reason because
it can feel a little sharp like it's
sort of bumping into the corners of your
hand i haven't felt that with this phone
the thing i like and dislike the most
about this design though is the finishes
so all the new iphone 12 pros have this
sort of matte finish on the back which
is nice it's actually a satin that
doesn't show many fingerprints in any
light which is awesome it doesn't change
much as it wears over time but then
you've got a glossy finish on the apple
logo
the camera bump and the stainless steel
band around the outside so the logo
that's fine i get it but we know they
could have made the camera bump matte
because that's what they did on the
regular iphone 12 yet they went with a
glossy finish just on this piece and
then combined with the raised sharp
camera rings this has the tendency to
collect a lot of dust every iphone 12
pro you see that's been outside of a
case for more than a few minutes or put
into a pocket is gonna have dust around
the camera modules this doesn't actually
change the performance of the camera so
it's actually not a big deal but the
dust is pretty much always going to be
there because of the rings the most
annoying part of the finish on these
phones for me though is the fingerprints
on the stainless steel rails they are
constant so much so that it's not even
worth cleaning in the moment when you
notice there's fingerprints on it like
they've nailed everything else about
this rail the power button is slightly
bigger and still very clicky love that
the mute switch is a staple that still
works exactly as you'd expect it to i'll
talk more about the rest of the button
behavior later but basically my ideal
iphone 12 would actually be a hybrid
between the matte back of the pro and
the matte camera bump and aluminum rails
of the regular 12. but guess what most
people
put the phone in case and so none of
that stuff about the finishes about the
grippiness about the corners will really
actually matter to you that much if you
cover up all of this engineering in a
plastic shell of your choice the size of
the iphone has always been pretty
reasonable although it's slowly crept up
in size over the years and this is my
favorite size iphone ever because it
feels just about as big as it can get
before i start to have to do hand
gymnastics to reach the notification
shade and the stuff in the top corner of
the screen for whatever reason apple
just refuses to adjust the software on
the gigantic iphone 12 pro max to really
take advantage of that bigger screen in
a meaningful way so i found the
trade-off in cameras and battery for how
annoying it is to use just isn't worth
it so the iphone 12 pro is a great size
the iphone 12 is an identical size and
the 12 mini if you can deal with the
battery shortcomings is the best compact
flagship phone out there right now i'll
link my entire video about that below a
couple other things about the design
though
this is a thousand dollar phone let's
not forget that it's a thousand dollars
and so there's a lot of these premium
design industrial design features
and this would be the perfect video to
shout out a lot of those things that we
typically skip and take for granted so
the whole body is sealed and ip68
certified i'm not the type to put it
under water and test that but it is able
to withstand dust and dirt and is
resistant to liquid submersion up to a
max depth of six meters underwater for
up to 30 minutes so it's always nice to
see premium phones that would survive a
quick drop in the pool or a toilet or
something like that and actually i also
used to do a lot more tests if you go
back far enough in videos where i would
literally try to bend the phone and see
if you could hear any flexing or
creaking or anything like that
phones these days just don't do that
anymore and this is no exception so
overall just in terms of raw industrial
design the iphone is exactly what we'd
expected it's great it works great it
looks great and it still has the widest
most vibrant ecosystem of accessories
the worst part about it is technically
that lightning port in a world of usb
type c but to most iphone users that's
just a default and we already know
apple's trying to get rid of that anyway
i'll link a video below the like button
or right up here in the corner to an
entire video i made just about that
topic the best part though
i still think is actually the most
underrated
the haptics so i'm putting this in the
design section because this is a
consideration from the very beginning
when apple's laying out the internals of
the iphone there is a massive space set
aside inside for a very large taptic
engine as apple calls it and it's really
good so instead of the previously
typical rotational vibration motor that
taptic engine is a linear oscillating
vibrator and it can deliver incredibly
precise convincing vibrations that
literally feel like taps almost like
you're pressing a real button or your
phone is tapping you in your pocket and
it's better than any other phone's
haptics i've felt right now this one in
the iphone 12 pro isn't necessarily
better than last year but it's just one
of those things that we skip because we
take it for granted but it's really good
apple's gotten so good at haptics that
they're comfortable replacing
typical buttons like a track pad on a
macbook
with just a flat piece of glass and a
taptic engine underneath it's just it's
that good also do i think that this
triple camera array looks kind of like a
stove top
yes do i think apple knew that when they
were making this phone
yes
but do i think they just went ahead with
it anyway because the memes are
inevitable and it's kind of also extra
press
yes so go ahead
put a case on it
[Music]
ah the screen
of the iphone always an area of great
debate just because how much do people
actually care
about the display this has always been
one of the most controversial areas of
the iphone
you remember the iphone 10r this is a
phone that launched at 749
and had a notably
low resolution
slightly above 720p
lcd screen right and part of the
internet went nuts at this like how
could apple of all companies be shipping
such a garbage screen on paper in a 750
phone when pretty much every other
android phone at that price even some
cheaper ones were 1080p at least and
even i was one of them just holding that
phone watching a video on youtube that i
knew was 4k
max out at 720p just felt borderline
unacceptable but it turned out
it was fine
it was fine people bought the phone they
enjoyed it there were blind tests it
passed so it felt like all those
articles and headlines about this screen
were for nothing because apple knew that
people didn't really care about this
sort of thing as much as we thought they
should but this is the same apple that
turns around and ships the iphone 12 pro
with an incredible screen on paper with
dolby vision a slightly higher 1200 nit
max brightness and a world-class color
accuracy that i guarantee those same
people don't notice so the question
might not be how good this iphone 12 pro
screen is as much as it's
how much do people really care about its
most controversial traits
and to me that's more fun angle so on
paper the iphone 12 pro rocks a flat 6.1
inch diagonal display like i said it's
not too huge it's a 2532 by 1170
resolution which puts you at an awesome
460 pixels per inch it's an oled display
that maxes out at 1200 its max
brightness which gives it hdr
certification and a 2 million to 1
contrast ratio it supports the wide p3
color gamut true tone automatic white
balance adjustments and it's coated in a
fingerprint resistant oleophobic coating
so here's where it gets interesting
there's a huge notch at the top
so this gigantic cutout stolen from the
top of the screen by the biggest notch
in any new phone out right now
do you care like functionally we all
know why the notch is there it's for
face id which hasn't really improved
over the years as much as i was hoping
but it uses an infrared dot projector a
receiver and there's an ambient light
sensor along with a 7 megapixel selfie
camera and an earpiece speaker and a mic
it feels like this huge notch has sort
of faded into our peripheral vision like
other phones added notches around the
same time as the iphone 10 and then over
the years they've all shrunk in their
notches doing everything they can to
minimize the interruption to a smaller
notch than to an even smaller notch and
then to a hole punch and then even to
developing tech to put the selfie camera
behind the display itself so the
iphone's notch is
still exactly the same it's massive this
is one of those things that personally
i hate it every time i'm looking at it
but
i've gotten used to it and apple's done
the calculus clearly that most people
have gotten used to it and don't mind it
and it's just part of the way the iphone
is and rumors point to it getting
slightly smaller next year but it's not
going away anytime soon even if we do
get touch id behind the glass in the
next iphone we're going to continue to
have face id so my take is fine i get it
but i would really like face id to start
working better specifically at more
angles so like when my phone is in front
of me on a table or on a desk i wish you
could recognize me from that angle and
unlock without me moving it or leaning
over it because other phones with the
fingerprint reader on the front let me
do that all right so then there is
the refresh rate
it's 60 hertz
this is as far as i know the most
expensive new phone
that doesn't have a high refresh rate
display yet
do you care so my take and you might
have seen this coming is i love me some
120 hertz absolutely it's the best thing
about a lot of the newest phones coming
out makes everything feel smoother and
more responsive and once you go 120
hertz it is really hard to go back to
60. except
for the iphone
the iphone is the smoothest 60 hertz
phone so i can kind of feel like the
best of the worst or the worst of the
best depending on how you look at it so
a lot of this has to do with the overall
performance of the phone which is great
but i'll get into that later but most of
this has to do with the 120 hertz touch
sample rate meaning the layer beneath
the display that tracks the touch input
from your finger and tells the display
to respond is refreshing twice as many
times per second as a normal 60hz
display so it feels very responsive and
really tight to the way your finger
moves on the screen and this is what
iphone users are used to so that being
said
the iphone can still benefit massively
from 120hz display and i know this
because the ipad pro has had 120hz
display since 2017 and it's incredible
so i'm bummed that the iphone 12 pro
doesn't have a higher frustrated screen
and i would be even more bummed if next
year it also doesn't but something to
note is that ipad pro is an lcd display
and one of the main reasons cited by
iphone defenders for why this phone
doesn't have 120hz display is because
they wanted to go oled too and apple
couldn't find a supplier that could make
as many high quality 120 hertz oleds as
they'd need to satisfy their high
quality control requirements and
millions and millions of units for the
iphone so maybe next year
i'm really hoping
but you know what else they made some
pretty big claims about for this iphone
screen
this new thing called
ceramic shield so the front of this new
iphone has a layer on top apple's
calling ceramic shield which isn't
ceramic but it is kinda shield it's
actually still glass but with a sort of
crystallized reinforcement and apple's
big on stage claim for this was four
times better drop performance so like i
said in my original review video i'm not
the one who's going to go out and drop
the phone over and over to try to see if
it somehow hits that 4x number but what
we did find out is it still scratches
out of level 6 with deeper grooves at a
level 7 and it will still shatter when
dropped it's not some magical next level
solution glass is glass
and you know the rest thanks zack but if
there is any observable improvement in
drop performance of the iphone 12 it's
most likely a result of the new flat
design since these phones are so flat
the rails are much more likely to take
some of that impact damage when you drop
it unless the phone lands completely
flat on the face which is unlikely
so with that stainless steel rail it's
gonna absorb a lot of the impact or it
could just be whatever screen protector
or case you have on your phone not the
magic of some ceramic shield so while i
do appreciate the effort to trying to
make better more resilient glass on the
front of the iphone
it's not magic oh and speaking of screen
protectors this is officially
unofficially but officially the easiest
new phone to apply a screen protector to
because of how perfectly flat it is in
case you're into that fun fact so the
iphone's display
incredible on paper
great color accuracy
flat plenty bright and sharp but also
still has a huge notch at the top still
stuck at 60 hertz and still scratches as
easily as ever it's glass
par for the court
there is a lot that goes into the
testing of a set of new smartphone
cameras and it usually ends up being the
longest section of the review just
because so many phones have gotten so
good that it feels like the camera is
one of the last things that really
differentiates them but here we are with
the iphone 12 pro and its triple camera
system so these are all top of the line
cameras but you probably already knew
that and honestly i could probably just
end it there like you know you're
getting good consistent point and shoot
photos
high quality videos and a good mic
you're set but that's not what you came
here for is it so there's a lot more to
say about these cameras so first of all
the iphone's cameras haven't really
changed all that much since they started
getting really good a few years ago if
it ain't broke they definitely don't fix
it here which is funny because the
headphone jacks also weren't broken but
i guess they didn't feel the same way
about that but the point is there's not
going to be some huge year-over-year
difference with the iphone cameras
because they don't have much to change
the sensor size is going to stay about
the same it's a 12 megapixel optically
stabilized sensor this one has an f 1.6
aperture letting in plenty of light and
it's flanked by a 120 degree 12
megapixel ultra wide at f 2.4 and a 2.5
x optical telephoto at f 2.0
a lidar scanner a mic and a flash to
finish off that stovetop the thing about
the iphone camera though that we
sometimes forget when we get super into
the technical weeds is it's designed to
be as simple as possible as easy as
possible to use while still achieving
results that are very difficult to get
any other way so when steve jobs
unveiled the original iphone back in
2007 stay with me this was one of the
slides he showed on stage it's a graph
of ease of use versus how smart
something is and of course he absolutely
trashes all the competition talking
about how they're not very smart or
they're not very easy to use
and the iphone is going to be way up in
the corner just a classic extremely
scientific apple chart on stage so while
the rest of the competition is
definitely caught up on those axes when
you just look at the camera
just the camera the iphone still
squeezes further up into that corner
than any other phone out there right now
this camera app is dead simple and it
has been forever everyone knows how to
point and shoot tap to focus if you
really need to and if you need any extra
controls they're typically hidden away
maybe one swipe and a tap away and when
you point and shoot the software does a
lot of heavy lifting thanks to smart hdr
thanks to multiple exposures thanks to
computational photography and thanks to
a great image signal processor that
makes it all happen very quickly it
would be really hard to get the results
that the iphone gets from any other
camera system with just plain point and
shoot and that is what the iphone is so
good at so i give it all the credit in
the world for point and shoot but what
about the few times when you actually do
want to get a little more custom what
about the times when you do want a
little bit more manual control
that is when the apple way can sort of
bite you because
there isn't a whole lot of that in the
stock
iphone camera app there actually isn't a
pro mode
in the iphone 12 pros camera now
fortunately they have gone ahead and
added pro raw which can give you a lot
more flexibility in the editing process
and there are some apps in the app store
that can help the shooting process for
you but
i guess what i'm trying to say is
there's a lot of really good smartphone
cameras and i think if you were to do
some sort of blind smartphone camera
test with a bunch of different phones
all in manual mode to dial in the exact
perfect photo
you might be surprised which one comes
out on top they'd all be really good
but where the iphone separates itself is
delivering consistent great results with
minimal effort so every year i describe
iphone photos in the review and every
year it's pretty similar they've got
this crunchy processed look but not too
over sharpened or over processed plenty
of dynamic range and detail for such a
small file and the iphone is notorious
for flattening out pictures with faces
making sure it always brightens up any
faces that might be in the shadows or
not exposed too well it will always
sacrifice the rest of the image if it
has to in favor of the subject or the
face which most would argue is the smart
thing to do in full auto but when you
spend a thousand plus dollars on a
smartphone there's going to be a lot of
people who want to do more than just
point and shoot and so that's where
there's some edge cases where the iphone
camera does get beat out by the
competition
zoom is a big one the iphone 12 pro
maxes out at 12 times digital zoom
there's a few phones out right now with
10 times optical zoom lenses that max
out in the triple digits for digital
zoom so you know then there's other
winners with even wider ultra wides or
winners with laser autofocus but again
as far as point
and shoot goes which is what most people
want out of most of their photos
most of the time
the iphone nails that now videos
this is where to me the iphone separates
itself as the best overall camera system
in a smartphone because there's another
layer to this which is app support so
you've probably seen by now some of the
memes about how a video from an android
phone will look like a blurry pixelated
mess on instagram while the one from the
iphone looks great
and there's a hint of truth behind that
and there's a reason for that the truth
is a video shot on a high-end android
phone and the iphone 12 pro
would be very similar comparable either
one could win
but a video shot inside of the instagram
app on a high-end android phone versus
the iphone 12 pro
will have a massive difference and
that's because for years many of the
most popular apps with camera functions
were simply screen shotting the
viewfinder in android phones instead of
actually plugging directly into the
camera feed like they do with iphones
there was an android police article just
the other day about how the galaxy s21
is the only android phone that doesn't
suck at snapchat because they actually
plug straight into the camera feed on
this phone and that may seem like a step
forward for android and maybe that's a
new future direction but
fundamentally it still comes down to
development if i am a new app making
something camera related and i can
develop one version of my app for as
many users as possible
i'm going to make an iphone version
because that's one version of the app
for many millions of people and trying
to make a bunch of different optimized
new versions for a bunch of different
android phones will just be a process of
diminishing returns so it's cool to see
a version once in a while for like the
s21 ultra or back when the pixel had the
visual core that would be cool once in a
while but
the iphone seems like it'll always have
this development advantage at least for
the near future which is actually the
main reason why i carry an iphone so
that being said if you want all the
in-depth info on the new cameras plus
the differences i found between the 12
pro and the 12 pro max with the larger
sensor better stabilization and improved
zoom yes i did make a video about all
those things but bottom line here is it
isn't much of a difference in most shots
until you get to the edge cases which is
where that stuff can produce less noisy
photos on the max
also you remember dolby vision but how
there is this huge deal made about the
fact that the iphone 12 series is the
first set of dolby vision certified
cameras and suddenly it was about to
become a huge deal and everyone would
start shooting hdr all the time well
that
hasn't really played out yet uh don't
get me wrong the video files look great
dolby vision hdr video from an iphone
looks amazing on an iphone and if you
send it to other iphones it'll look
phenomenal on those displays but the
second you have to export it and send it
somewhere else
that's where the experience starts to
fall apart iphone's dolby vision video
is using hlg which stands for hybrid log
gamma and without getting super into the
weeds on file formats and nits
it's just not compatible everywhere so
if i shoot adobe vision hdr video on my
iphone and i want to share it somewhere
like twitter instagram or even an apple
tv where it's not supported well then
the video gets converted and mapped to
an sdr image fitting all of that hdr
information back into a standard dynamic
range screen and to me that sdr image
doesn't look great so dolby vision hdr
video looks super good when it works and
i've seen some awesome examples even on
youtube of iphone 12 pro hdr videos and
if you have the right monitor or the
right phone then these videos look
awesome but i'm still waiting for the
best most reliable hdr pipeline for
getting a video shot here
to hit your eyeballs
compatibly beautifully every time but in
summary overall the iphone cameras
pretty good
[Applause]
[Music]
24 7. i think it would be foolish to
overlook magsafe magsafe is one of the
most interesting new features on the
iphone 12 series not because of anything
amazing physically i mean it's just a
wireless charging puck with some magnets
in it that align with the back of the
iphone simple but the extra layer on top
is there's rumors apple is eventually
going to be getting rid of the charging
port as early as this year so that means
we could be looking at the future of
charging on all iphones and then the fun
part is also brings the potential of a
whole ecosystem of magnetic iphone
accessories enabled through magsafe so
first of all on the name
i get why they called it magsafe it's
beloved branding but
it doesn't quite serve the same utility
as the original magsafe so if you rely
on this magsafe puck to charge your
phone and you accidentally bump the wire
the phone is absolutely coming with it
it's hardly any more safe than a normal
wire but that being said it works slaps
on the back just like that charges at 15
watts and that's fine uh there are a
number of pretty decent mag safe
accessories kind of like this that are
just cases that are compatible with
magsafe meaning uh if you slap the
charger on the back it will also
magnetize and work through it this
happens to be one of nomad's leather
cases for the iphone 12 pro max here
but other than that i was kind of hoping
there would also be
a separate ecosystem of just magnetic
accessories that slap onto the back of
the iphone so i got this car mount from
belkin which has a somewhat tacky rubber
on top of metal that's supposed to hold
the iphone in place without any clamps
which would be super cool just with the
magsafe magnet inside and this to me was
going to open up this whole new world of
things sticking to the back of the
iphone with magnets
and it's
barely
good sometimes it might depend on your
car's suspension at this point but for
me it slowly sinks down while i'm
driving until it eventually falls off
the magnets so it feels like this
magnetic charging puck is the best
magsafe accessory out still five months
later although there is some stuff in
the pipeline by moment that i'm hoping
to get my hands on that looks pretty
cool they make some big claims about
also having a proprietary magnet array
that's a little stronger
i'll believe it when i see it but long
story short i'm calling it an accessory
now but it may be a necessity in the
very near future because if the next
iphone truly doesn't have any ports then
you will have to wirelessly charge your
phone every single time
so i guess this magsafe puck would be
the best way to do that the biggest
bummer for me would really just be the
charging speed so wireless charging is
already pretty inefficient but there's a
lot of innovation going on with
companies pushing super fast wireless
charging speeds 40
50 60 watt wireless charging
apple
not doing that at all magsafe is 15
watts period actually it's 12 watts on
the iphone 12 mini and even if you plug
into a faster brick it's going to limit
that charge to that 15 watts long term
it is true that this is better for your
battery health and if you want your
phone to last a number of years then
that's what you're getting here but
sometimes you just want to charge it
fast you know
i guess that's why they're calling it
magsafe because for your battery
it is safe
[Music]
the iphone 12 pro has a 3
687 milliamp hour battery on paper
that's actually pretty small we're very
used to flagship smartphones nowadays
having anywhere from four thousand to
five thousand milliamp hours sometimes
more rarely less but thanks to the
iphone's efficiency their vertical
integration their optimization all the
classic stuff we've talked about for
years that number
doesn't really mean nearly as much as
the actual day-to-day performance
which is great on the iphone 12 pro i
can consistently get six to seven hours
of screen on time which is really good
for a phone of this size on heavier days
though with a lot more navigation or
just more taxing use maybe i'm pulling a
lot of data or playing games or using
the camera a lot then it'll drop faster
the a14 bionic chip inside is very
powerful so it can move through battery
quickly enough to kill it end of day
with less than five hours of screen on
time but for me anyway that's a pretty
uncommon day so the only thing you
really start to think about more and
more after the phone comes out is
longer term battery health
and to be honest five months later still
is a pretty short amount of time in the
relative
grand scheme of things as far as
batteries go but you want this thing to
last three
four maybe even five plus years and
iphones have a good history here and
this iphone 12 pro that i've been using
still shows 100 battery health and
that's just
kind of it for battery apple's kind of a
bit boring in the battery department i
was just talking about it in the magsafe
section but apple has never led the
industry in charging speed they have
never led the industry in battery size
and there are android phones left and
right doing split battery cells across
foldable form factors even doing split
battery cells to do faster charging in
parallel there are phones doing 50 60
even 100 or 120 watts which is
absolutely unreal
and can get you from dead to full
sometimes in half an hour the iphone has
never done any of that it's just a
simple
modest sized cell that lasts a
reasonable amount of time
the iphone
isn't just a piece of hardware it's the
software that runs on it and it's the
ecosystem that surrounds it
now there isn't really a whole lot of
extra stuff to say about ios on the
iphone 12 pro specifically that's new
here in fact that's actually one of the
things people like the most about it is
it is incredibly consistent they don't
change too much year over year they
never have and older iphones will have
literally the exact same software
experience as the new iphone as soon as
the new iphones come out so all i really
have to say about ios this time around
is the stuff that was supposed to be
new
widgets so widgets finally came to ios
after having them on android for the
past 12 years or so so when apple comes
late to the party on something usually
there's some reason they're going to do
it the apple way or they're going to do
it better even though they weren't first
and now that i've had them for about
five months on the iphone 12 pro
they're actually kind of better and
worse at the same time so ios 14's
widgets are really good i actually think
their implementation in ios while it's a
little less custom
does feel a little more polished and
controlled as you'd expect from ios but
when i first went over all of ios 14's
new features in that video we saw a few
widgets apple built in that demonstrated
huge potential there's widgets smart
stacks and some really informative
widgets to give you live updating
information they were all fairly clean
and consistent visually you still can't
quite put it exactly where you want on
every home screen but this felt like the
ios way and so now it was up to all our
favorite apps and developers to update
their apps to make great widgets like
they did on android so where they ended
up worse
is there's actually not as many and
they're still not quite as customizable
as they are on android now maybe it's a
bit unfair to expect all my favorite
apps to have updated with widget support
like they've had a decade to do on
android but just in the apps i use five
months later there's a waze widget on
android but not on ios there's a
soundcloud widget on android really
useful playback controls not on ios
there's an asana widget on android but
not on ios so there are less widgets and
overall less customization within the
widgets themselves
but overall the quality of the widgets
feels a bit better
so sounds about right for apple that
being said i was really curious how many
people really use widgets and so i did a
poll on twitter asking you guys you know
how many of you guys use widgets on your
home screen how many don't and it turns
out about 75 percent of you do whether
you're on android or on ios which i
found very interesting so then we've got
the new app library all the way to the
right now this isn't quite the app
drawer that so many of us love on
android but it's getting there and it's
definitely useful for finding everything
in one place and not needing to have
every single app on a home screen or in
some folders so the iphone's home screen
situation will continue developing over
time
and speaking of developing over time
so will
the ecosystem you can't talk about the
iphone without at least touching on the
ecosystem around it so apple's ecosystem
gets a little more complete surrounding
the iphone every year just this year
they added the homepod mini they added
airpods max
and the long rumored air tags are
probably coming soon and in the walled
garden analogy that can either be the
inside of that garden getting even more
lush and beautiful or
it can be the walls of the garden
getting a little bit higher
either way i think they're kind of both
true the point is it's making it harder
to leave i really don't have any
fundamental problem with the way ios
works it's mature enough now that at
this point any change they make is a
small little added feature or a little
experiment you know widgets were easily
the biggest new thing but they've pretty
much locked in stuff like their swipe up
gesture and the timing and
responsiveness of animations even if it
is a little jarring coming from a square
edge instead of a rounded edge and
they've locked up the camera ui
fundamentals for so long pretty much
everyone on earth knows how they work by
now i don't like the power button for
example how it doesn't just turn off the
phone it also triggers siri with a long
press remember when power buttons just
turn phones on and off but the most
consistently frustrating thing in ios to
me that i wish they would evolve
is not notifications although that could
also use some work too
but settings just the fact that there
are so many settings separated from the
app and moved into the settings app it's
just been annoying for a long time but
guess what the iphone is still a
ridiculously popular phone for a reason
it doesn't change too much year over
year there's nothing too dramatic
happening versus the last one people
understand it they're used to it
both my parents use an iphone at this
point and it would be really hard to
recommend they switch to another phone
even if
that phone is technically better
the cost of switching is high
and that's on purpose
[Music]
okay so the arrival of 5g
on the iphone finally 5g has been a
topic we've hyped up and talked about
for a long time and there were a lot of
big promises made when 5g finally
arrived on the iphone they opened their
whole keynote with verizon ceo on stage
talking about 5g for a while so it had a
lot of promise to it
most notably
5g just got real well we have the
benefit of hindsight now were they right
did 5g just get real by adding it to the
12 series
no i mean mostly no 5g
rolling out to the world is an
infrastructure thing it is going to be a
slow
literal building process for that to
happen so that won't suddenly happen
quickly because of any one individual
phone that being said
yes there are now many millions more 5g
customers out in the world because of
this new iphone but here's a more
interesting question
do you even want or need 5g
in the first place
because here's the thing we've seen tons
of promises of this wild awesome 5g
enabled future with robo taxis and
remote robot surgeries and insanely fast
internet speeds everywhere you go but as
you saw in my 5g explained video
we're not there yet i mean realistically
5g speeds are not actually that much
dramatically better than 4g speeds
sometimes they're a little better
sometimes they're actually worse
the rare exception to that is when
you're in a stone's throw range of a
millimeter wave tower in which case you
might get incredible speeds
until you walk away i actually
demonstrated pretty clearly in my video
that if you're within eyesight of that
millimeter wave tower you get fantastic
speeds but as soon as there's an
obstacle between you and the tower or if
you literally even go behind a window or
turn your back to the tower then you're
gonna lose some of that signal so 5g is
cool 5g has a lot of promise for the
future but it is not going to suddenly
get real because of one phone or any one
technology the one thing you can say
about the iphone which is why they're
using these terms is there are now
millions of people out there who are
walking around with their first 5g phone
some of these people will live in an
area with 5g coverage and will benefit
right away
some of these people will live in an
area that doesn't have it but that's
about to get 5g coverage in the next few
years and they'll see that benefits soon
and some of these people will live in an
area with no 5g and they won't benefit
at all those people can just turn 5g off
and use the iphone just like their last
one also one of the fun facts is if you
didn't upgrade to a 5g phone the
millions of people who just left the 4g
network with their 5g iphones may
actually make your 4g speeds a little
bit better to apple's credit they've
managed to minimize 5g's effect on
battery life pretty well some early 5g
phones and this happened with 4g 2 had
worse battery life because of how
inefficient it is to constantly hunt for
a 5g signal and you might have even seen
that now deleted tweet of verizon
account asking people to turn off 5g to
improve their battery life but i
actually found that the iphone does a
really good job with power management
it's well known now that it doesn't
actually connect to 5g all the time it
really just switches it on when you're
downloading something or using a lot of
data when you really need it if you're
not it might show you the 5g logo but it
won't actually be connected to 5g and
it'll save you some battery and honestly
you probably never notice so the effect
on battery life has been minimal
and a step has been taken forward
towards getting the world's internet
users on to 5g
but it definitely didn't suddenly get
real
[Music]
okay so you know how every year as soon
as a new iphone comes out there is a
rapid and dramatic search for literally
anything that could be possibly wrong
with this new phone and if there is
anything then that becomes a headline
and we're all just trying to find the
latest the newest gate signal strength
drops when i hold the phone in a vice
grip antenna gate some iphones have
charging problems charge gate maybe the
iphone can be bent in half that's bend
gate i did an entire video called iphone
gates explained you can watch that but
this year it's been pretty quiet
right there's not that much
controversial stuff about this iphone
but i don't know it doesn't feel right i
feel like there's always got to be
something there's got to be something
for the youtube channels to feast on for
views there's got to be some sort of
gate that we can talk about right
what is the gate oh maybe maybe
it's the display again right there's
always some sort of element of
controversy with the screen and this
screen is nice but it is a thousand
dollar phone with a comically big notch
and it's somehow still 60 hertz and
apple's getting away with it so surely
that's worth the gate maybe there's also
been some occasional bubbling up of uh
oled tint issues i've seen a couple
forums and youtube videos talk about
green tint on the iphone's display
hasn't really been enough of that
happening for apple to respond to it yet
but it's kind of out there or oh
actually maybe it's just the fact that
it still uses lightning
actually no it's a what's the iphone it
uses lightning every year i mean we knew
they were never going to go to usbc for
the iphone that's not really a gate
actually you know what
i think i know what it is i think the
bar
for a gate
is something that gets a response
from apple
it's got it's got to crush that
threshold like you have to find
something that's so major that apple's
engineers didn't find and their testers
didn't find but it's such a big
admission that apple has to go then
respond to you that
would be a gate and maybe the only thing
that qualifies for that
would be
so there is no charger in the box of the
iphone 12 series and so this it was
pretty significant of course it didn't
get a reaction from apple but it was so
big that it needed a sort of
pre-reaction which was an explanation by
apple in their keynote about why they
were doing it so we saw them take the
environmental angle you know less
charges in the box means less e-waste
when people would throw them away less
wasted space with packaging and more
iphones shipped per truck per train per
plane per pallet efficiency saving the
world now when you actually break this
down yes you are saving some e-waste by
not shipping charging bricks that people
could potentially throw away if they
don't need them
but on the other hand
the cable that ships with the iphone is
a usbc to lightning cable
and most people who own iphones don't
have a usbc charger so they have to buy
that usbc charging brick anyway which is
more packaging and more money and now
they're throwing away their old bricks
and it's kind of not really making any
difference so as much as we all hate
this and we can kind of see through the
environmental angle
we can also sort of see how this is
already starting to become
normal so since this iphone shipped in a
small box with no charger the xiaomi mi
11 has also shipped in a small
chargerless box but they'll still give
you a charger if you ask for it and then
the galaxy s21 series did the same but
they're not trying to give you a free
charger at all when apple does something
the rest of the industry takes notice
they're all watching and they often
react and so just like we saw with the
headphone jack where there felt like
there's about a one year buffer time
where you could make fun of what apple
was doing with the headphone jack before
you delete all your ads making fun of
them and copied them in your next phone
i feel like the buffer time is even
shorter with this one but the difference
in the danger with this trend is
all the innovation we've been seeing
over the past few years in battery tech
and charging tech and this like race to
the fastest charging phone
does that
just end
i really hope not so that's what really
makes this a gate to me at least is it's
not just the okay apple's not shipping a
charger with the phone anymore and oh
look how greedy this seems like they're
being but the ripple effect that this
inevitably has on the rest of the
industry and at the end of the day i
think that's what makes the iphone such
a fascinating product to begin with is
it you know it started off by changing
the world in 2007 but every time they
update it after that it has these second
and third order effects on the rest of
the smartphone world around it that's
what's so crazy about the iphone there
are companies that make entire phones
based on rumors of what apple might do
in a future iphone just so they can beat
apple to the punch
that is wild
[Music]
all right that's i think that's it i
think that's everything that i've wanted
to say about the iphone that i haven't
in some way in some video somewhere i'm
glad we did this this is uh if you made
it straight through to the end of this
video watch the whole thing
well we've been through a lot together
so i appreciate you also you might
notice it's a different shirt this time
that's what happens when it's a long
video it takes more than one day to
shoot
but if you skipped directly to the end
this conclusion here
well you missed the most exciting part
but either way yeah i'm super curious
what you guys think to me it's it's not
just about making a longer video just to
make a long video it's about being able
to cover
all of a topic instead of just a narrow
slice of it like we normally are
compelled to but hey if you guys watch
the video and you enjoyed it we can do
more of this type of stuff so let me
know in the comment section below also
down below right below like button are
all the references and all the links of
all the stuff i talked about during this
video as promised
cool
that's it thanks for watching now a word
from the only sponsor brave enough to
tack at the end of this gigantic video
expressvpn shout out to the sponsor of
this video expressvpn so quick question
how did you choose which internet
provider that you use
actually i'll probably just answer that
for you you likely didn't have a choice
or if you did you're pretty lucky
because in most areas you don't have a
choice and so because these isps
essentially have a monopoly over the
areas that they serve if they start
doing things you disagree with or if
they start to track all the websites you
visit even when you're in incognito mode
what are you going to do switch
you can't so using expressvpn stops this
by rerouting your connection through a
secure encrypted server so your isps
can't see a thing and also rerouting
your connection through a different
server can actually be kind of fun for
example if i want to watch modern family
it's not on us netflix no problem i just
connect to a server that's in the uk
refresh
and i can watch it and it's not just
modern family you can get thousands of
other shows on netflix basically
unlocked just by switching your location
when you use expressvpn so if you don't
want your isp to have complete control
and knowledge over every website you
visit and you want to unlock more shows
it's kind of a no-brainer you can grab
expressvpn today and if you use my code
or go to expressvpn.com
mkbhd that'll get you three extra months
free
thanks again to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video